hey this is damon labyrinths with wired
and it says constantine awesomer more
importantly this is Constantine
tautomers Tesla Model S we're going to
do today is put the Model S through a
slightly different kind of test we've
downloaded the sidecar app and we're
going to pick up people that need rides
in San Francisco and drop them off and
get their impressions on the car and see
how the model s holds up to it
hey how's it going man you're looking
for sidecar we're gonna be filming you
guys mainly just using this gentleman's
model s this is Constantine by the way
which serious Tesla's is room it's a
model s it's one of the founder series
so why are you driving for psycho I
gotta make payments dude i personally
like sectors you actually get real
people right all right driving you
around and you know you sit in the front
seat usually this person one of the rare
ties if everybody had Tesla's inside
garbage sweet no hit this this ride is
on the on the house come on yeah rated
him counter even though threatened not
to pay I gave him a five star rating
okay off we go
so this is their second car they came
out with a roadster first uh-huh and now
they're actually making an honest-to-god
vehicle that can carry five people
obviously yeah and a cooler and such an
attempt and yeah then we saw a room in
the front we did wonder a little I'm
sorry if someone could afford driver
test my that's right so you guys can
actually see the vehicle you're going to
picked up in ya on the app that's cool
can you pick like what vehicle can you
like look down and say no I don't want
to be MC pacer but I'll definitely take
my hair right Brook here can I get a
picture with this heart yeah absolutely
hey is this Michael yeah Michael this is
your side car ride how many people in
your crew hi guys just you alright we
will be there in about seven minutes
according to our navigation system so
what else is this display thing you know
so you've got cool web browser
absolutely gianormous completely enable
and everything the only thing it doesn't
do this video's probably good reason
there yeah there is correct flash is the
same as much that sucks in traffic this
visit thanks have a good nice to meet
you please enjoy thanks for the ride hey
thanks a lot for being run love your car
you